her pictures tend to be positive
optimistic even cheerful that alone is
nothing unusual at the lagos photo
festival what is noteworthy is the fact
that fatty abubakar lives in Maiduguri
known around the world as the birthplace
of the extremist Islamist group Boko
Haram more than 20,000 people have been
killed in Northeast Nigeria almost three
million people have been forced to flee
but Abubakar shows us another side of
life people gonna expect such a thing
from a beauty they expect that children
are happy that there's so much I yes we
do have also but we have an opposite
side where people are happy new life is
no more she shows the beauty of her
homeland borno state on Instagram and
Facebook and has a large following then
way on the other side of Nigeria in
lagos the photographer is praised and
respected i'm very excited about i think
she needs to be encouraged and you know
it's a platform for her to show her work
side-by-side international photographers
on an equal footing and really to share
her own stories I share an experience is
working in it very difficult in the
community farty Abu Bakar is using the
festival in Lagos to network with
colleagues she is also taking workshops
to hone her skills at the moment she
still works for an aid organization
she's not a full-time photographer my
place you don't get a lot of that you
don't get culturally seminal acceptable
for me as a woman
doing photojournalism so when I come
here feel very welcome and we have
discussions around you know how to
improve yourself you know you hear
stories from all over the world so I
love for lego photo as a platform the
positive feedback in Legos as well as
the lively media interest have
encouraged her to continue and she is
optimistic not only about her career but
also that Boko Haram will one day
disappear from her homeland and from the
news